[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so this particular one is a patreon
sponsored review because yes monk just
being able to you know help me cover my
bills these days you can actually
commissioned me to review ones and this
one is one of those this was something I
think I had heard the title of I knew
almost nothing about although I kind of
suss out what it was pretty quick the
normal heart now the normal heart is a
film it was an HBO film so I I didn't
check this I presume it premiered on HBO
the network and didn't hit theaters but
it is based off a play of the same name
which is a largely autobiographical play
written by a playwright named Larry
Kramer and it while it is very much
influenced by his own life experiences
you know it does the usual names changed
and that sort of thing but it is set so
both the play and the film and I'm only
reviewing the film I only mention the
play guess that's what this is based off
of and as I said written by someone who
was there during the events that are
being depicted it is set during the
early 80s and it focuses on a gay man
played by Mark Ruffalo and it tracks the
for several years of the AIDS crisis
focusing in New York where it was
especially concentrated and really
looking at the the fallout of all that
on multiple levels the fallout
in terms of within the gay community the
fact that this crisis was largely and
fairly blatantly ignored by anyone with
the authority or the means to even
attempt to help the way that the
community fought against being or the
way the community they fought each other
and also looking at you know some
specific relationships has one or more
of the people involved have to watch
someone they love that they're in a
relationship with wither and die
watch this community of friends and
lovers watch dozens hundreds of people
that they know die you know typical nice
light watching um no it's heavy I mean
it's very heavy and they should be given
the subject matter it's got a good cast
too in addition to Mark Ruffalo who I
mentioned Taylor Kitsch is in it
Matt Bromer there were that number of
other people who I recognized but I
probably couldn't Jim Parsons is in it
Denis O'Hare that was another one I was
trying to think of it's a very good cast
of people Julia Roberts isn't it playing
a wheelchair-bound doctor who was one of
the first you know first medical
professionals really trying to track
this thing and do something about it but
she's just not getting support and yeah
it's it is heavy
the moments of hope are there in the
beginning they don't stay for very long
and it's very good and I think it's
something that people especially lgbtq+
people my age or younger would benefit
from seeing because speaking personally
I was I was technically alive you know
and the as this outbreak was was
building but only just you know I was
born in 82 so I've always you know grew
up sort of being close enough timeline
of my life wise to it to sort of have a
vague idea that it was a thing that
happened but I think having a better
sense of how much it tore apart and
destroyed this community and you know
specifically gay men but the thing to
keep in mind is that whether you know
right or not
lgbtq+ liberation has largely been led
by gay men not to say the gay men are
fighting for everyone else but they make
the headway first and it's a starting
place for the rest of us to to try and
get in there and it was a setback for
everyone in in addition to just the
incredible loss of life and the
devastation to communities and to
families and yet at the same time I feel
like this given the material and given
how well presented it is I feel like it
should have hit me harder than it does
and
knowing that these days especially that
I'm a very easy mark I cry a lot at
movies these days like almost an
embarrassing amount but I didn't give
more than a few sniffles out of this and
I think it's because what it's doing
really should have I mean I don't know
how it works onstage but just judging it
as a film this really should have been a
miniseries this should have been a total
of four or five hours because for the
amount of time that it's covering the
number of characters that it is asking
us to have some degree of investment in
even at two hours it's not even that it
feels rushed it's just it's jumping from
them so often I just was left feeling if
I had spent a little more time with any
of these individual characters and plots
I'd probably be slightly more invested
and will be slightly more devastated by
why I'm now seeing happening and
normally what I would see something like
that in most stories I'd say we need to
Chuck some of these subplots and some of
these additional characters because you
know they're sapping some of the energy
out of the room here I actually wouldn't
recommend that because I do think the
breadth and scope of it is very well
conveyed through how many characters we
are seeing deal with this so I do think
- and again this is not to say that it's
not impactful and it's not good and I
wasn't biting give me a lot to think
about and really sort of wrap my head
around but it didn't hit me as hard a
motional E as I thought it would and I
think that is just lacking the raw time
with with all of the characters involved
and I think had this been a miniseries
had this been four or five or even just
three hours that I I probably I probably
would be in a box of tissues as it
stands I didn't but that's not to say
that I wasn't touched and moving that's
not say microwatt I saw this could I had
I absolutely am the it also gave me a
better understanding because it
addresses a question that like I never
asked out loud because you know it just
seemed rude and weird I wouldn't know
who to ask but was always kind of in my
head which is once they realize it was
sexually transmitted why why didn't
everyone just go abstinent all of a
sudden and there's a couple things that
play there the first is that how quickly
symptoms show varies from person to
person so someone can spread it before
they know they're infected and but it's
sort of the bigger question like there's
a scene where Julia Roberts is trying to
impart to this group of gay men that
they are risking their lives by engaging
in sexual activity and she says flat-out
look I don't have all the answers but
why would you risk it right now just
stop and intellectually I was kind of on
her side but there was some really
interesting points made by the men in
that scene by the fact that for gay men
especially at that point in time their
promiscuity was basically their form of
revolution there weren't any
discrimination protections for gay men
depending on where you were in the
country there were still sodomy laws on
the books from gay men the mere act of
sex was an act of rebellion it was an
act of civil disobedience it was an
affirmation of their existence of not
being in the closet their simple ability
to be with other men in a place like New
York which obviously as this whole thing
went down the authorities turned a blind
eye and let them a lot people die but in
New York that was more tolerant where
they could be themselves and they it was
important to them to be able to live
themselves to the fullest and a it was
good for me to have that perspective
because the promiscuous gay male is a
bit of a stereotype but it's also
especially going back to you know
pre-aids times are you know at the start
of all of this there's a fair amount of
truth to it
and I always kind of took it as like a
man yeah they did
like I had always I suppose I'm not sure
how much I thought of I guess I'd always
brush-off was like oh yeah cuz guys are
like they're always horny and they'll do
anything yeah yeah I was like that at
one point sure why not but to realize
that there's more to it than just gay
men are always horny that it was for gay
men their ability to be promiscuous was
about the one thing that they had over
straight people because there was no
risk of pregnancy and it was a big part
of how the communities were knit
together and you know that sounds very
superficial but when the very nature of
gathering these men together is that
they are all attracted to other men it's
going to lead to a very sexually charged
sexually focused environment and group
and community sex was important to them
and to ask them to stop wasn't like
asking most other groups to stop and
it's things like that and in sites like
that in addition with having like I said
a much better sense of the scope and the
size and the speed at which with which
this just was like a bomb went off and
seeing a variety of things you know some
people having coughs and almost flu-like
symptoms
some people degrading mentally losing
control of bodily functions this this
film does not flinch and like I said
even though I feel that it would have
been more affected at along a runtime
I'm glad I saw it and I feel like even
though I know it's fictionalized knowing
that it is it ties back to a work by
someone who was there I feel like I got
an insight into something that I only
ever just kind of had a vague
understanding of and I think it's good
and healthy for me to have a better
understanding of some of the history of
the community that I'm a part of I mean
I'm not a gay man but I am part of the
lgbtq+ community and as I said you know
that's a part of that just like trans
rights are part of that just like pushes
for lesbian and bisexual inclusion are
part of that and it it would behoove me
to know more about the history of this
community that I'm a part of but I'm
also not I'm not a researcher by Nature
I'm not built to sit down and read about
this stuff but if I can sit down and
watch something that is 2hours that
gives me insight that I didn't have
before I think that is two hours well
spent the normal heart have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever
your thoughts are drop something down in
the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
to do as well there's the patreon I
already mentioned even a dollar a month
is a huge help plus you know like
subscribe the usual stuff other links
down there to link to my book social
media etc click on them they'll take you
places but you don't have to at the end
of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]